so i spotted something outside if it's
what i think it is i gotta get one
yes
they look so real
[Music]
you ever do something in life where you
just look back and think
well that was a waste of [ __ ] money
hello if you didn't know i have a
podcast called trash taste and last year
we did a figure challenge where we spent
1 500 buying anime figurines to decorate
our office this year thanks to all your
support we've moved to a new bigger and
better office so we thought why not up
the ante and spend ten thousand dollars
collectively on anime figurines to
decorate so that's what we did if you
watched last year the rules are going to
be the same we're going to go to four
stores in akihabara lushing ban a stop
army army and mandarake with
approximately three thousand dollars to
spend we're gonna have a bunch of
challenges to complete in each store
with some also overarching challenges
and this time we have to spend a minimum
of 500
per store the winner is the one with the
most points and the loser is going to
have to do some sort of forfeit so
this is what happened hello weebs
and welcome
to the anime zone
i mean the yucky design you have to be
so loud yes i did okay look we're
starting off in the archiba zone if i
don't win this first challenge as the
anime zone
i'm removing the zone from my name okay
i'm just gonna be called the anime all
right if you watched last year you'd
recognize trashbox cone he's coming back
for another year so we're just gonna
withdraw the first two challenges now
get a non-anime figure that's so easy
though in here maybe it's gonna be hard
in here are we counting like jrpg video
games no that's not anime if it doesn't
have an anime if it has an anime then
okay okay okay i have
oh
get the most expensive anime figure you
can find
oh get the jojo figure do the exact same
pose oh [ __ ] easy enough what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
and my second one is
get a figure that can beat goku
get a figure from a game that connor has
played
are you [ __ ] kidding me do they sell
apex or league figures good luck guard
close your eyes and randomly grab a
figure slash
that's easy all right i guess without
further ado we should uh go in the store
and complete our challenges let's go but
before we move on i just wanted to talk
about today's sponsor
surfsharkvpn come on guys it's 2021. you
should know what a vpn is by now but in
case you don't virtual private network
keeps you safe and private by covering
up like a mask everything you do online
when your device connects to the
internet all that information is blurred
out and anyone who tries to sleep on you
won't be able to see what you're doing
or where you're doing it from but that's
not all because you can also virtually
travel the world in just one click yes
you can virtually change your ip address
to many countries from across the world
i've personally found this very useful
when i've been feeling homesick and i've
wanted to watch bbc programs but uh
can't access it unless i have a uk ip
address surfsharkvpn also allows you to
stay safe on public wi-fi and also send
and receive files safely and securely
because nobody needs to know the amount
of anime luge you're sending to your
mates all right
you know who you are so what are you
waiting for protect yourself online
today by clicking the link in the
description and using promo code giga
for 83 percent off yes that's 83 percent
off than four months for free thank you
serve shark vpn for sponsoring today's
episode back to the video all right so
this is the first store lashing van and
there's just something about going into
an anime store when it's completely
empty i feel like a kid in a candy store
right now so let's get looking before we
go any further i wanted to introduce my
camera woman for the day hey guys
it's your girl okay
is that it i don't know what else to say
let's sit snap go subscribe all right
give me the [ __ ] camera she's gonna
be my partner in crime for the day for
the day or for life
all right so i've got two challenges
i've got to find the most expensive
figure and a figure from a game that
connor's played now i know kind of plays
apex i know conor plays league that's
pretty much it so i have no idea what
else he's played i'm just gonna have to
like take a stab in the dark and even
hope that he's played any of these games
this one's already pretty expensive
we've got some final fantasy figures for
110 bucks that's aerith though i'm more
of a tifa guy really damn boy she thick
i don't know how we've done this but
we've inadvertently just walked into the
hentai corner so this is just hentai
figures can we show that on youtube
sydney sydney sydney this is not your
channel sydney no
no
please sydney i want to get monetized
please both of these are 220 which is
the most expensive figure thus far cynia
what do you think of these figures i am
very curious about this one just because
the tits look so big i want this holy
[ __ ] it's a yom figure this is a figure
from one of my favorite artists he did
the art for miri tights this one i'm
definitely buying this is 121 oh [ __ ]
the only thing that can combat lead
figures for price is apparently
fate figures because of course it would
be holy sh this is 340
who is this oh it's this [ __ ] oh okay
holy [ __ ] look how badass this is 550
for this [ __ ] this isn't the figure
anymore we've gone beyond the territory
of figure we are just at girthy statue
we're gonna see if we can find a figure
more expensive i'm really hoping we
don't just so i can buy this figure
anything more expensive than the fate
figure i'm honestly just tempted just to
like throw a hail mary and just hope
that connor hasn't found something more
more expensive because i actually just
want to buy the fake figure oh that's
pretty expensive is that more expensive
than the fake figure i don't think it is
i don't think it is you know i'm
thinking i'm just going to go for the
fake figure i'm going to put my faith in
fate fans that they're gonna get me
through this game we got some re-zero
figures none that are as expensive as
the fate figure though
oh no
that's a 700 figure it's ameliors wow i
really want this figure
i really want this figure so bad oh no
do you want a wind guard or do you want
to have taste i don't know i feel like
[ __ ] subaru right now immediately
you're just [ __ ] me over we got
badasses compared to [ __ ] amelia come
on really are you really gonna make me
choose what's it gonna be
you know i'm
i'm gonna follow my heart my heart says
this [ __ ] a 700 media statue i've gotta
go with this are you with me on this
sydney yes i'm with you okay good that's
why i'm marrying you connor what you
done connor what have you done
kind of just like thieving the [ __ ]
store already all right we're gonna
quickly find a game is it the figure
that we need to buy [ __ ] it is a figure
[ __ ] i'm more out of luck we don't have
much time to wiana okay 15 minutes 15
minutes to find a figure from a [ __ ]
game that god has played connor why
could you not play more jrpgs jesus
christ is this monster hunter has conor
played monster hunter this is love live
bang dream and idol master i shouldn't
be here right now um fate figures
connor's played fake go right he's
playing fago surely surely he used to
play arc knights but there are no arc
knight figures around i'm like drawing
out straws here this is my last chance
does yu-gi-oh count as a game has connor
played yu-gi-oh mega man mega man [ __ ]
would have played mega man there's a
bunch of figures here anime anime anime
love live love live love live sword art
online that counts as a video game right
connor why have you not listened to me
and played persona 5. i've been
recommending this game to you for about
five years now but no you refuse to play
jrpg god i hate you it basically comes
down to
i got it we got it boys we got it we got
it mario thank you thank you chris pratt
thank you so much it's a me and mario oh
i could just be simple and buy this
pikachu one i'm gonna save a budget i
need every cent okay here's what i'm
thinking do i buy the emilia
no is it worth losing a point let's just
go buy our figures so that came out to
uh
670 dollars i can barely hold the girth
of this thing look at that i think i've
actually found a character figure from a
game you've played oh really oh yeah
yeah well how to see it or is it a
surprise no it's not a surprise so that
was lushing ban um i don't know if i've
made a massive mistake by not buying the
amelia figure but i guess we'll leave it
to fate so we'll see you in the next
door i get it what we'll leave it to
fate
so here we are the second store we are
back in the archiba zone this time we're
going to a-stop which is the same store
we went to last year so once we go in
you're probably going to recognize it
but before we go in let's find out what
our challenges are cindy how do you
think i'm doing so far well you've spent
the most so far but you know i kind of
took an l on one of the
don't say that don't say that jerry's
right there trashbox [ __ ] round two
jesus christ joey ah sydney get
something super etchy buy a figure from
a shonen series oh what the [ __ ]
i think you got that last time i did i
did get a character figure from fifth
and all-star okay
thank god
this you might actually have a chance
here no i do i will have a chance i've
seen them sell it here my second one is
get a figure from a series that you
recently watched
get a gojo figure
get a female character figure okay the
gacha gods are finally online you can
literally get two points
let's
go so once again we are in a stop and as
you can see i am surrounded by figure
boxes i got figure boxes to my left
this is my right i got bigger boxes to
my left i got connor right behind me i
think our first mission is to find a
lewd figure now cindy we've got two eyes
working for us right now that's a good
nipple right there that's some good
nipple i like them i like them a lot do
you think this video is gonna be
monetized no so how this store actually
works is that this is actually a
secondhand figure store all these boxes
are owned by someone and they're the
ones who set the price it's basically
just real life ebay so like because i
was so focused on the challenges for the
previous thought i forgot that we have
some overarching challenges as well
which are on screen right now so now
that i have a bit more time to focus on
other challenges apart from just
figuring out if i want to spend 700 on
amelia i think the one i'm gonna try and
find is a figure that's close to uh
sixty nine dollars or four twenty
dollars let's see what we can find
[ __ ] like there's there's a gojo
figure there's a gojo figure right there
who's go joe are you are you serious oh
that's pretty lewd cindy can you like
not put a pants can you not put her
panties on the screen sydney this is
438
which is pretty damn close to 420 and
it's a lewd figure worst girl though she
is
but
we're here to play a game 69.69
see if you can find something 69 holy
[ __ ]
oh you know what i kind of want a uh
what's her name again how have i known
for [ __ ] sake echidna that's it i get
50 off everything in this box so i can
get echidna for six dollars sometimes
you just gotta look out for good deals
oh my
god
[Applause]
i don't even care if it's sword art
online i'm getting this point oh but it
says 70 off oh sh
[ __ ] the one time i don't want a
discount and there's a discount oh
berserk we've got berserk we can do
berserk or we can do goblin slayer
they're both the same thing right i
swear to god sydney i i swear to god
that's so close that's so close why is
every sword art online figure 69 or
close to 69 is this chapter 16.5 all
over again
um but it's 20 off
are you kidding me god what do you keep
getting i keep getting 69 dollars but
every box that has a figure that's 69
has a 50 or 60 no
come on japanese people why is no one
pricing their [ __ ] 69 exactly sydney
stop stop is this black goku or goku
black don't shoot he's not black this
man isn't black oh it's a rent a
girlfriend come on i've got it i've got
her that's the cheap chisel figure i'm
getting that i've just bought waifu so
far i didn't know that uh when two
girlfriend freak is already out so i'm
really happy i got one for that jeep
initially i thought look how cool this
guts figure was until look at the color
of his face why is he green it's seasick
guts this is what happens when you spend
12 years on a boat man he's spilling his
guts oh my god sydney stop you know what
i'm gonna get black goku that goku
deserves to go on our wall [ __ ] i just
realized that's an anime original film
but it's so expensive i found another
promo figure for much cheaper i'm gonna
go for it i don't think i can get a
better price than that what is that that
is nightmare fuel is this what happens
when you put the anime figure in the [ __ ]
jar all right so we've got 10 minutes
left so we're just gonna cash out now
we've spent over five hundred dollars
and i hope that we've just got three
points with one figure i'll be honest i
don't remember what some of these
figures are but i'm gonna keep them on
anyway how do we buy the figures and
they stop we note down all the figures
on the piece of paper and then the store
clerk will get all the figures for us
and confirm which figures we're actually
buying oh yeah i did put a chizzaroo
figure in there of course liked it
what are we doing
okay and that is it we spent
572
and 50 cents that is it for a stop so we
will see you at the third store which i
believe is amiyami once again so see you
there finally some representation for my
ethnicity linny look it's uh your
favorite store it's the minion store all
right so we are finally in miami and uh
this time we have to wear these face
cards for this store specifically but
we're gonna be doing three challenges in
miami all right let's do the first one
go for it get a figure for an anime that
joey has watched in 2021
good luck with that oh no get something
chosen by the other two
get a figure from an incestuous series
and shout i love incest why can't i get
that one get a figure from a show that
the boys have not watched good [ __ ]
luck with that good luck with that this
is doable but
i'm gonna be hurting do a squat for
every zero figure i see buy a wall easy
get a male character figure oh thank god
thank god i got an easy one get a
character plushie get a figure of a
character that is american
all right let's go all right let's let's
just get a plushie let's get that [ __ ]
out of the way what is this i thought
this was like the body of an ugly
bastard does that not look like the body
of another bastard a girl can dream
oh no even has like a little vagina stop
talking go on i found something that
you'll love here let me see let me see
come here come here there's a bunch of
re-zero figures right here
and right here aren't there there's a
bunch here one two
one two three four five six seven eight
i've done all that seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirty four and fifty-six
oh i'm knackered i'm already knackered
character plushies oh my legs hurt so
much you see any flashes you like what
kind of flashes do you like uh
not kingdom hearts what about a pokemon
plushie i don't know pokemon's basically
look it's my uh it's my favorite anime
to alchemist amazing anime this is my
favorite character believe he's a voice
by vik magnana what about these ones oh
my god i'm getting this is that a ham
tower no it's like a hamster car cute
how do you feel about getting a
demonstration burn it oh my goodness
this this is adorable as [ __ ] do i have
to get a character plushie i just got a
little little baby man all right let's
let's try to find some actual anime
flashes
oh my god you have to [ __ ] get that
i'm kidding
that's gonna age like milk and like too
i don't care okay this is this is the
cat this is perfect this is perfect why
is the hair on among a shelf who needs
this much among the [ __ ]
which one looks more sus right all right
let's let's get the sassy barker put
this on my pile don't show the rest of
the voice all right and there he goes oh
for [ __ ] oh for [ __ ] sake
at least you can't accuse me of skipping
leg day now oh i like this figure let's
not put that one in frame sydney oh look
at her butthole should i get something
gundam i know alan wants me to get
something on them i have to build all of
these these are all model kits why can't
mecca just like have like a figure that
i can display
what is this og mecha fans where are you
at i would prefer if there was a mecca
that i actually knew this looks like a
really cool [ __ ] ava figure i think i
might just want this for myself like how
big is this [ __ ] massive that's how
big look at this chunky boy look at that
hey gaunt hey i'm going to scratch your
back
what's an incest enemy
because uh
i'm just gonna be blunt i don't watch
that [ __ ] joe just find a kiss like this
you know yeah yeah dude i'd be all over
that [ __ ] if i found it you gotta think
outside the box okay it's not about the
incest anime
it's about the anime with incest in it
i'm not gonna solve the issue for you
but i'll give you some wise words incest
is in the heart it's what was shown out
on the sleeve sometimes you've got to
look within to find the incest just find
a little sister and see where that goes
oh it's eris i didn't know they made
mushoka tensei figures now no i made it
i got a by the way okay you seen this
can you do this spot real quick
oh
oh nipples it's me what's sydney what
the [ __ ] why are you here again i don't
i don't know what figures to buy
honestly let's get a hentai figure cena
you always want a hentai figure hey
this is just like hello i'm a discord
mod and i watch anime at this one i'm
just shopping basically completed my
challenges i am happy though because i
haven't found a figure that's more
expensive than the fake figure i've
bought yet what's the coolest figure
here i don't know there's quite a few
cool ones in the hentai aisle
stop what's going on baby oh
i want to get the aeros so unless i can
find roxy for now i just wanted to show
a tennessee figure oh for [ __ ] sake
all i did was turn around my legs are
jelly right now my legs are actual jelly
oh man they got wargreymon
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
i've seen ava before okay i don't
remember there being a giant enemy
lobster get in the crab shinji is this
pre-built metal build damn it if only
alan was here so he can answer if this
is pre-built or if you have to build
this yourself i'm gonna guess you have
to build it yourself honestly i would
love something mecca for the studio but
i have to build everything these are all
plastic model kits mecca can you just
give me a figure that i could just put
on my desk without having to build
please i'm begging you no one says i
just needed to get one character plushie
we've got the among us plushie what can
we add to that how about
steve
i think stephen among us would be a good
duo so i'm gonna just gonna put that
down there we are back in the hentai
corner i'm not going to leave this place
without buying at least one hentai
figure and you know what i'm going to
let
the queen of degeneracy really pick
herself so here's some nice b-roll while
sydney chooses the figure because i
don't want to show all the figures that
she's going through right now sydney
what are you thinking do i want that big
titty succubus or do i want that girl
eating a condom keep in mind we need to
show this in the office sydney i have
made my decision i'm going to choose a
figure that is literally just an ass
an
because
god comes up with things in mysterious
ways
oh my god my son we gotta get that what
do you think of this figure it's just an
ass
it's just an ass you're welcome
there's no front it's just an ass don't
let the boys see oh shh
i forgot i have to buy something that
they asked me
why would i want that would the ram
won't be any better or would the ram one
be better which one are you going for
you can have either remo there exactly
look at the mama car
give me a milk well actually it's 300
bucks oh yeah okay yeah yeah sure you
could have that wait wait wait how much
is this one we are making an official
statement here on camera we have chosen
forgotten to buy
the milf i've got some cool figures i
want to buy you don't have to do it for
the point you can fall for the point
i'ma [ __ ] do it i won't do it that
was a 300 figure [ __ ] i got 330 i want
to spend left i want to buy another fate
figure a key to ulta hell yeah so you're
not going to spend anything in mandarake
sometimes you roll for a character and
you don't get them so what do you do you
buy them irl okay all right well i think
we've got a pretty good haul here so
let's go cash out i kind of forgotten
how much i bought it i think i've spent
about a thousand i bought a lot i bought
a lot of figures what the [ __ ] okay
we're at 1020 did i buy anything else no
no okay yeah yeah and that is it boys
i'm not quite sure how much i have left
the last place i don't think i have over
a thousand see you at the fourth store
and we are at the final place which is
mandarake i don't know why i pointed at
this like there was like a logo here
anyway if you don't know what mandaraka
is it's a really really big secondhand
store that has anime stuff a lot of
collectibles so you can find some really
really rare collectible here that you
can't find anywhere else i'm excited to
see if we can find some really cool
stuff but i'm also scared because i'm
not sure how much of a budget i have
left and out of all the stores it feels
like this is the one store that won't
have a cap on like the most expensive
item you can find really rare items here
for like upwards of like ten thousand
dollars maybe even higher all right last
challenge of the day get a figure of a
fake character that god does not own on
fgr yes get a figure from a show that
all the boys have watched that means
i've got the same challenge that i did
last time i think which was ask the
store staff to recommend a figure for me
and buy it in japanese why joey let's go
all right so i think this is a bit
unfair because uh jerry's got nabi as
the cameraman who is a fate expert i'm
gonna call [ __ ] we're not checking
your account we're making a
well-educated guess as to what you might
have joe joe
this is meant to be on your own fake
knowledge what if it was an actual
tactic that i invited navi as my camera
have you not been listening to all the
times i've talked about fate if you did
then no it should be it should be an
easy question i haven't got because i
don't give a [ __ ] this boy cheating
again my god so this is mandarake and as
you can see there is a totally different
vibe when it comes to the pricing okay
as soon as we walked in there's one
figure that is already our entire budget
that is a 3080
ava figure just to give you an idea of
the pricing that we're working with we
could have some really really expensive
stuff but we could have some really
cheap stuff so let's go have a look from
my first impressions we have got a lot
of like old-school [ __ ] we've got
transformers we've got old-school mecca
oh we got uh yeah zoids what is the last
time since i saw zoids jesus christ so
this is actually the eighth floor that
we're on right now mandarake is eight
floors most of the character figures are
on floor seven and eight so that's what
we're going to be focusing on today but
i want to go into the other floors to
see if we can find some like interesting
things what is that i am a hero curry
plate that's such a unique item are
these real katanas should i buy a
[ __ ] katana i'm gonna play a
costume we have a lot more lewd figures
all right let's start on the floor below
we're going really old school now this
is marzinga z i don't know og mecha fans
where are you at
my og mech knowledge is just
non-existent thank god i didn't get the
must buy the most expensive figure
because i'd be absolutely [ __ ] this is
six thousand dollars that is more than
double our budget right now what is that
is that marzinga z we got the super
sentai corner it's like og kaiju stuff
because we've got marzinga there we've
got ultraman you've got trading cards as
well we got fake go cards no [ __ ] way
this is ghatra in real life we've
reached the pokemon corner we've
actually got charizard and blastoise
it's like 700 for a charizard i'm sure
someone who knows a lot more than
pokemon cards than me will tell you if
this is a good deal okay so i've gone on
one of the other floors uh just to have
a look around this is like mazinger z
right tetsujin 28 go can truly be
considered marzingazi right i think so
my god mecca fans are gonna like crucify
me now i swear to god what is that astro
boy what is that so i spotted something
outside if it's what i think it is i
gotta get one
yes
so they just straight up cell airsoft
bang bang bang what the hell look at
that look at that oh my god what's in it
i got an idea trash chased we love to
[ __ ] on america a lot right but what if
we embrace part of american culture i'm
going to buy like bang bang bang and i'm
going to present it to the boys that
looks like a [ __ ] american bang bang
bang how much i have left my budget we
got to buy them should i get that one
are you able to take that one home let's
do it let's do it let's do it we're
going full american on this podcast wait
wait can you get demonetised for showing
bang bang bang but it's an airsoft bang
bang bang right this is so [ __ ] big
and girthy they literally have to
dismantle the shop to take it out that's
how big this thing is i can't believe
i'm fighting bang bang bang this is this
is heavy this is actually heavy holy
[ __ ] this is real metal um how do i get
away with this i think my biggest worry
is that i get arrested on the way back
uh that's that's what i don't want to
happen i just spend a 300 for one
reaction that i'm not getting able to
show the product so uh let's hope it's
worth it i've completely forgotten that
i have to do my challenge so i'm just
going to do that now
uh character
uh anyone anyone you recommend one piece
yeah sure let's go one piece
robin then can i uh can i get that one
yeah good choice i i found someone with
good taste thank you very much all right
and that is the last point done so let's
try to fill up the budget now can we get
a hunter
i know you want more hentai figures
sydney okay this is not what we're here
for i want to find like a gundam figure
or something or a mecha figure so i just
googled it and uh we found a mecca
figure this one's for you alan because
my editor alan will not shut up about
gundam hathaway okay so i'm buying this
for you alan now we can stop [ __ ]
talking about it does that mean we have
300 left over yeah can i get a hentai
figure then okay
you can get a hentai figure sydney oh my
god sydney stop you want the asanagi
figure there's so many i want okay i
like this one a lot cause it's just
really aesthetic but also asanagi so i
kind of want awesome why do you want the
asanagi figure because it's culture it's
beautiful we can get the asanagi figure
okay okay we're looking for something
for 2000 yen 2015. it's a it's a saber
t-shirt sure why not how much is it oh
no it's 2 200 right i think i've
calculated this
correctly that's just like a plushie i
don't [ __ ] know man this is just a
plushy of i don't recognize this and
this is a phone case holder no this is
too much [ __ ] i did something for like
exactly 2 000 but everything is like two
thousand two hundred yes was the tax
included i can't remember that are you
gonna take the l i'm going to take a
risk i hope i haven't gone bust we are
going to go downstairs to pay away from
the rest of the guys and that is it i'm
not gonna reveal my final price right
now you can find that out on the trash
taste podcast where we're gonna
basically figure out who spent closest
to 3
33 so with that said i'll see you
outside with the boys and gamers that
was it if you want to see their
reactions to what i've bought then head
over to the trash taste podcast right
now if everything goes to plans then the
episode should be released right now so
you can see their reactions also check
out their videos if you want to see
their point of view as well and uh that
was it as i said you can check out all
the different points of view in the
description below and also the podcast
unboxing episode and once again thank
you to lashing ban a stop ami ami and
mandarake for letting us film there i
had a lot of fun this year so links in
the description if you want to check out
any of their stores hope you guys check
out the podcast because at the moment of
recording i literally don't know who's
won or lost yet anyway though that's it
from me today i've been giggup and i'll
see you all next time